- [Narrator] Since
the dawn of man,
the black hairline has been
a symbol of protection.
Literally; the further
back your hair line,
the less protection
you had from the sun.
In the 300s, Africans would
mark their foreheads with black
to create the appearance
of a hairline.
This technique did not
last with everyone though.
From the the past, to today,
we embark on a wonderful
journey into the world of:
the black hairline.
(dramatic orchestral music)
People of all races
have hairlines of
all sizes and shapes.
But why is the black
hairline so important?
- The African-American
community has built
a social caste system
based solely on hairlines.
Let's look at this
dramatization, for example.
That's not a TV.
- Wow, your hairline,
crispy AF.
- I respect that.
- [Narrator] However, a bad
hair line warrants no respect.
- Damn, your hair line,
trash.
- Wow, this disappoints me.
- [Narrator] There
are different types
of African-American hairlines.
- Straight up?
- Yeah, yeah, straight up.
- [Autotune Voice] Straight up!
- [Vintage Radiocaster]
From downtown.
(seagulls cawing)
- [Smooth Male Voice]
I'm just coolin'.
- [Autotune Voice] Damn!
- [Narrator] The
African-American woman
is greatly affected
by the hairline.
- Lemme see you
without your hat.
- No, I'm good,
I ain't got not
line up right now,
you know.
- I'm sure you look
the same without.
- No, I don't!
- Let me see!
- C'mon man, you're
playing too much.
Man, I told you I
had a new haircut.
Gimme my hat back.
- [Narrator] The
African-American woman
does not have to worry about
the increase of facial features,
because studies show
83% of attractive women
do in fact have
big-ass foreheads.
The popular braided
style of hair
creates tension on the hairline,
which can confuse their
emotions to peers.
What is the future of
the black hairline?
We sent our scientists to
investigate one company
that has the answer.
They've been featured
on numerous magazines.
They are the line elite;
a five-man company
dedicated to the crispyness
of the black haircut.
(scissors snipping,
bottle spraying)
(chimes ring)
- Now in the year 2020,
the hairline will be in
the state of recession.
2040, the hairline will be
in the state of depression.
Now, by the year 2050,
the hairline will be
in the state of Texas.
So we gotta fight
for the line, people.
Fight for the line.
- [Group Chanting]
(group cheers)
Fight for the line.
- [Narrator] Throughout
our adventures, we see
the different ways
African-Americans
express themselves.
The black community
maintains its own systems
of fashion and hair culture
that constantly morph
and change over time.
I'm Ben Putin, and this has been
Black National Geographic!
(dramatic orchestral music)